years ago in the height of summer
my father told my brother and me a story
he only told it once
and he refused to speak of it ever again
when he was a young man
in the year of the false spring a great
southern lord held the largest tourney
westeros had ever seen
in the largest castle westeros had ever
seen knights and lords from across the
seven kingdoms made their way
drawn by the spectacle and the size of
the champion's purse
even the king was rumored to be
attending though none had seen him in
years
ours is a small house and my father had
come only to be part of the magnificence
whose like he'd never see again one
afternoon
he was walking across the field enjoying
the warm spring day when he was set upon
by three
squires none were older than 15 yet all
were bigger than him
this was their world as they saw it and
he had no right to be there
they snatched away his fear and knocked
him to the ground cursing him for a frog
eater
every time he tried to rise they shoved
him down and kicked him when he curled
up on the ground
but then they heard a shout that's my
father's man you're kicking
howl the she-wolf lyanna stark the young
daughter of lord rickard stark
warden of the north and my father's
liege lord lyanna laid into the squires
with a turny sword
scattering them all my father was
bruised and bloodied
so she took him back to her tent to
clean his cuts and bind them up with
linen
there he met her brothers wild brandon
who led them
the quiet eddard and benjen who was the
youngest of the four
that evening there was to be a feast in
harrenhal to mark the opening of the
tourney
and lyanna insisted that my father
attend as he was of high birth with as
much a right to a place on the bench as
any other
man she was not easy to refuse this wolf
maid so my father borrowed suitable
clothes from benjen and went up to the
great castle
under haren's great roof my father ate
and drank with his fellow northmen
a black brother beseeched the knights to
join the night's watch to snickers and
smiles
prince rhaegar sang a song so sad that
it brought tears to lyanna's eyes
but when benjen teased her for it she
poured wine over his head lord baratheon
drank down a night of skulls and kisses
in a wine cup war
my father remembered a beautiful woman
with purple eyes
who danced with sir barristan selmy and
several others
as the end of the evening approached
brandon stark asked her for one more
dance on his shy brother's behalf
and so eddard stark shared the last
dance of the celebration
with lady ashara dame abruptly
the hall went quiet the mad king had
come after all
and was now entering the hall with his
kingsguard he hadn't left the red keep
in years
and none could believe the state of him
his long yellow fingernails
tangled beard and ropes of unwashed
matted hair
made his madness plain to all nor was
his behavior that of a sane man
for in the blink of an eye he could go
from hysterical laughter to weeping to
rage
but when he commanded sir jaime
lannister to kneel before him and swear
the oath of the king's guard before half
the lords of the realm
a cheer burst from the crowd for sir
jaime was much admired for his courage
gallantry and skill with a sword amidst
all this merriment
my father spied the three squires who'd
attacked him attending their nights
lyanna saw them too and pointed them out
to her brothers i could find you a horse
and some armor that might fit
benjen offered my father thanked him but
gave no answer
our people sit a boat more often than a
horse and our hands are made for oars
not lance's much as he wished to have
his vengeance he feared he would only
make a fool of himself and shame his
people
eddard had offered my father a place in
his tent that night but before my father
slept
he knelt on the lakeshore looking across
the water to the isle of faces
and said a prayer to the old gods the
next day in the tourney
the three knights whose squires had
beaten my father unseated their
opponents and earned a place among the
champions
but late in the afternoon as the shadows
grew long
a mystery knight appeared in the lists
he was short
and clad and ill-fitting armor cobbled
together from different suits
on his shield was painted a heart tree
of the old gods
a white weirwood with a laughing red
face
the mystery knight dipped his lance
before the king and rode to the end of
the lists
where the five champions had their
pavilions you can guess the three he
challenged
whoever the mystery knight was the old
gods gave
strength to his arm all three knights
fell before him
none were well loved so the common folk
cheered the knight of the laughing tree
as the new champion was soon called when
his fallen foes sought to ransom their
horses and armor
the night of the laughing tree's voice
boomed through his helm
and told them teach your squires honor
that shall be ransom enough once the
defeated knights chastise their squires
sharply
their horses and armor were returned and
so
my father's prayer was answered the king
was furious
in his madness he suspected a traitor in
his midst
perhaps even the newly made sir jaime
lannister
whom he had already sent back to the red
keep that night
the king asked lord robert baratheon to
take to the lists and unmask the mystery
knight
declaring him no friend of his but the
next morning
when the heralds blew their trumpets and
the king took his seat
the night of the laughing tree had
vanished
all they ever found was his painted
shield
hanging abandoned in a tree my father's
tale ended here
he never spoke more of harrenhal though
he must have seen prince rhaegar's
victory
some whisper that prince rhaegar himself
had arranged the entire tourney in
secret
as a way to gather the great lords and
address his father's apparent madness
perhaps even remove him from the iron
throne
but when i asked my father about this he
only shrugged sadly
what rhaegar intended none can say
but all know what he did barristan the
bode
they call me to my face i know what they
say behind my back
barristan the old i find myself visited
by the faces of the kings i have served
the faces of those i swore to protect
the faces of those
i failed young prince aerys
for 20 years his reign was peaceful and
prosperous
aries was well loved by his subjects and
respected by his lords
but as years went on harry's temper
soured
he became obsessed with dragons and fire
and the swords of the king's guard
couldn't defend him from the enemies he
saw lurking
in every shadow my king
went mad but there was
hope his son and heir
prince rhaegar was everything a kingdom
could hope for in a ruler
he was strong but gentle wise and
cautious
and a good friend no matter the wounds
aries dug
into the realm we had faith that his son
would sew it back together again when he
ascended the throne
then came lord wentz tourney at
harrenhal
the largest ever in westeros ironhorsed
every man against me until only prince
rhaegar remained
we each set our feet in our saddles and
lowered our lances
and charged and i fell
muddy and bruised are then watched
rhaegar present lyanna stark with the
victor's crown of roses
though she was betrothed to robert
baratheon and rhaegar himself was
married to elia martell
we all know what happened after have i
been a bit quicker with my lunch if i'd
chosen a faster horse
perhaps i could have spared the kingdom
from the destruction that came after
you